in a previous video we derived the
formula for the sum of a finite
geometric series where a is the first
term and r is our common ratio what i
want to do in this video is now think
about the sum of an infinite geometric
series and i've always find this found
this mildly mildly mind blowing because
or actually more than mildly mind
mind-blowing because you're taking the
sum of an infinite things but as we see
you can actually get a finite value
depending on what your common ratio is
so there's a couple of ways to think
about it one is you could say that this
the sum of an infinite geometric series
is just the limit of this as n
approaches infinity so we could say
we could say what is the limit
what is the limit as n approaches
infinity as n approaches infinity of
this business
of the sum
from k equals zero
from k equals zero to n of a
times r
to the k
which would be the same thing as taking
the limit as n approaches infinity right
over here so that would be the same
thing as the limit as n approaches
infinity
of all of this business let me just copy
and paste that so i don't have to keep
switching colors
so copy
and then paste
so what's the limit as n approaches
infinity here let's think about that for
a second i encourage you to pause the
video and i'll give you one hint think
about it for rs greater than one for r
is equal to one and actually let me make
it clear but think about it for the
absolute values of r's greater than 1
the absolute values of r equal to 1 and
then the absolute value of r less than
1.
well i'm assuming you've given a go at
it so if r if the absolute value of r is
greater than one as this exponent
explodes as it as it approaches infinity
this number is just going to become
massively massively huge and so the
whole thing is just going to become or
at least you could think of the absolute
value of the whole thing is just going
to become a very very very large number
if r was equal to 1 then the denominator
is going to become 0 and we're going to
be dividing by that denominator and this
formula just breaks down but where this
formula can be helpful and where we can
get this
to actually give us a sensical result is
when the absolute value of r is between
zero and one we've already talked about
we're not even dealing with the
geometric we're not even talking about a
geometric series if r is equal to zero
so let's think about the case let's
think about the case where the absolute
value of r
is greater than zero and it is less than
one what's going to happen in that case
well the denominator is going to make
sense right over here
and then up here what's going to happen
well if you take if you take something
with an absolute value
less than one and you take it to higher
and higher and higher exponents every
time you multiply it by itself you're
going to get a number with a smaller
absolute value so this term right over
here this entire term is going to go to
zero as n approaches infinity imagine if
r was one-half you're talking about one
half to the hundredth power one half to
the thousandth power one half to the
millionth power one half to the
billionth power that quickly approaches
zero so this goes to zero if the
absolute value of r is less than one so
this we could argue would be equal to
would be equal to a
over
1 minus r
a over
minus r so for example if i had the
geometric series if i had the the
infinite geometric series let's just
have a simple one let's say that my
first term is one and then each
successive term i'm going to multiply by
one-third so it's one
plus one third
plus
one third
squared
plus
one third to the third plus and i were
to just keep on going forever
this is telling us that that sum this
infinite sum i have an infinite number
of terms here this is this is a pretty
fascinating concept here we'll come out
to this it's going to be my first term
it's going to be my first term 1
over
1 minus my common ratio one minus my
common ratio in this case is one-third
one minus one-third which is the same
thing as one over two-thirds which is
equal to three-halves or you could view
it as one-and-a-half
that's a mildly amazing thing